pawel kowal lok fährt am liebsten die
langen touren einmal türkei und zurück
da ist er dann zwar weg von seiner frau
und den beiden kindern aber nach zwei
wochen hat er dann wieder ein bisschen
zeit für sie ziemlich oft rücken schnell
am schlimmsten sei es nachts einen
parkplatz zu finden ständig raststätten
essen ist auch nicht gesund und danach
zum schlafen bleibt auch nur die ödnis
der fahrerkabine
doch es gibt hoffnung
die branche ist von nachwuchs schwund
gebeutelt die lkw hersteller sind
besorgt um ihren absatz dieser man sagt
also muss man das fahren schöner machen
das schlafen zum beispiel siegfried rote
ist entwicklungsingenieur bei daimler
er hat nicht nur die ligen breiter
konzipiert er will den fahrern auch
stille
wärme
und massage ermöglichen
rote und seine kollegen sind
erfindungsreich geworden um die
entscheider im konzern für die nöte der
fahrer zu sensibilisieren
fettleibigkeit nimmt unter truckern zu
besonders in amerika das muss
ergonomisch berücksichtigt werden beim
bau der kabinen
der korpulenz anzug hat schon einiges
bewirkt
topfit sollen die männer demnächst durch
europa düsen rote bekam von seinem
auftraggeber vor acht jahren ein budget
um ideen zu finden die den beruf des
truckers auf werben also testete er
wochenlang die fernfahrer realität am
eigenen leib
sein befund
einmal diese soziale isolation dann die
unglaublich schlechte hygiene die
schlechte ernährung also fertig viel und
dann konnte ich überhaupt nicht
vernünftig schlafen weil es einfach zu
laut war
ich hatte nicht die möglichkeit
irgendwie ein bisschen sport zu machen
geschweige denn auch schmutz wäsche zu
waschen
also soll es künftig aroma duft geben
und beruhigende bewegtbild motive auf
als sechs monitoren für internet- und
videospielen nach dem motto die
rastplätze kann er nicht ändern aber er
kann den käfig in dem die fahrer wochen
lang sitzen ein wenig vergolden
beispiel das licht in der kabine dem bau
für verschiedene stimmungen und glaube
richtig dafür verantwortlich dass der
perücken synchronisiert wird
das heißt die ausschüttung der hormone
melatonin serotonin und cortisol wird
dadurch mit gesteuert und so wird ihr
biorhythmus synchronisiert nichtwissen
rhythmus synchronisiert wenn sie zum
beispiel den jetlag haben
der biorhythmus also scheint immer
wichtiger zu werden lässt sich aber auch
anders anheizen
per fitness element müsste eben nur
genutzt werden
dann klappt es vielleicht doch besser
mit dem gemütlichen powernap
zwischendurch
den sesseln einfach per knopfdruck nach
hinten legen und beine hoch auch das
wäre neu in der branche
jetzt heißt es nur noch warten auf die
erleuchtung der entscheider im daimler
konzern